see you guys probably heard about this
whole Mozilla Firefox CEO
fallout situation up Brandon ike
I is the CEO or was the CEO of Mozilla
until last week he donated thousand
dollars to prop eighty
in 2008 the bad side of prop 8 and then
OK Cupid found out about this and they
blocked
the their site OK Cupid on Mozilla
Firefox browser
hello there Mozilla Firefox user part in
this interruption if you're OK Cupid
experience Mozilla's new CEO Brendan I
can
opponent equal rights for gay couple we
would therefore prefer that our users
not use Mozilla software
to access OK Cupid okay so then of
course this blowed up
into I blew up into a giant fire storm
he stepped down
but now it turns out that there might be
a little hypocrisy here
because the CEO OK Cupid has that
donated money
to to some things that perhaps
he's not so proud have now okay cubans
founder and CEO San Diegan made a five
hundred dollar donation to a
congressional candidate who oppose
same-sex marriage voted against the ban
on sexual orientation based job
discrimination and
or probation at Gate adoptions records
show that you can who is also the scene
York Match dot com donated $500 dollar
to representative Chris cannon his
Republican in Utah in 2000
and poor I so before we get to the
hypocrisy for this guy
were you guys happy to see the CO was
over
going at it is a thousand dollars that
he did
a roughly five years ago I think about
in dollars I think it's a significant
amount of money and I think you know
when people with they put your money
where your mouth is
people vote with their dollars so enough
and also it's not just that money it's
also
his or lack thereof on like retracting
or even
are the statements supporting a donation
even years later write a review
indication that he doesn't still feel
that way out but
a lot has changed in five years and it
is possible that change and it was only
a thousand dollars so was this a bit up
an overreaction
disorder he didn't get fired he stepped
down yeah I think he had the opportunity
to say
you know what week it was 2008 things
are different now
I had evolve my thoughts on gay marriage
and and you know i i shouldn't have done
that he had some opportunities
I apologize yeah any really just kinda
stood with that and I had
so even if his butt have been evolved
rush chimney
shady have the right now but should
someone be have the right to be the CEO
a pretty public company and not be four
gay marriage in it's an interesting
question I guess maybe the answer is
probably yes but I think it's I don't
think of our business that they are
doing it will mark the loud music
yet or you amines and you know I didn't
like
you know green people I wouldn't say it
because like with my customers a green
yeah in like it just it just gets shut
your mouth recognise or
yeah I don't know it was just like such
a distraction but he kind of had to
if they were going to move forward at
all in an earlier he had he had had to
saddam what you guys think about the the
hypocrisy the OK Cupid
so he bands the Mozilla the you know
Explorer whatever
on the for insight but it turned out
that he has donated to some things that
he may not be so proud of do
but I think the difference being that
since this is like years and years later
he has had the opportunity to say you
know i i supported the stand I don't
support it now
and so I think people can kinda make
that difference she Asian yeah
I are you are you guys fans love Urban
Outfitters
manager I like Urban Outfitters yeah I
think that t shirt might be a bit and is
it not
it is not going to take it up yeah I
trust you I know you gladly will take it
up have a lower
yeah but because the owner at the
president and founder of Urban
Outfitters has donated money to rick
santorum's campaign he said the mother
anti-gay step
so it is weird how we store to pick and
choose who we decide to relegate what we
know that and you keep all the time
everywhere something that is from Urban
Outfitters and people recognize that
people
email me India you wore that shirt from
Urban Outfitters I can't believe you're
supporting their
so when your personal policy on it so
you do where Urban Outfitters despite
knowing that i mean i full disclosure I
have plenty of Urban Outfitters yeah I
mean I II
didn't realize when I bought the shirt
that I was
you know in the worked on the internet
you can't win no matter what you do
yeah and and you can try to trade as you
couldn't you could donate a million
dollars to schools Africa
people email you and say you know
there's a lot of work that needs to be
at home who are you
rent right I alright so with every
thought since we're winning the war
you're right that we're winning this
game or it I mean we're getting gay
marriage in every state every couple
weeks
some activist judge does something we
get the more gay marriage okay
doing in a weird way that the gay
community should somehow figure out a
way to be a little more gracious
somehow for these people should we be
goodnight gracie is exactly which we
figure out a way to be a little more
open to these people that maybe did
things five years ago
that whether they're proud of it or not
I don't putting I know it's putting it
on us
which i think is very difficult because
we still don't have for quality but I
think there's something to that
that there's these people holding on to
something that they're losing and maybe
we should somehow figure out a way to
embrace them a little bit warns that
everyone is fighting all the time
I can go out to work with yeah I think
the question that people are trying to
ask is even if he felt this way
have your top profit the default do you
feel this way now
and that giving people that giving
people who are in positions of power and
influence on the public eye
opportunity either yes or now and
you know we've all we all grow and learn
I'm not the same person I was five years
ago and and so
people are wanting to see where their
leader stand today and so I think
the leaders who are not being as tactful
as they should be are getting a little
bit blowback
your yet another yeah I I am I don't
care so much what someone said
ten years ago and when the whole thing
with the gay rights movement is that
we're hoping to change hearts and minds
been
when we do that with someone we can hold
that against them that that their
opinion is now different
and and I think that's a great thing if
they still think that I should get
married
I won't I will not have compassion give
him a problem yeah